All right, let's get to an audience questions for
the week. First one increasingly relevant is the
vaccine rollout continues and vaccines are made
available, available to more and more Americans.
David, do you know people personally who
are refusing to get the coronavirus vaccine?
You know, I do. And I don't really know conspiracy
theory types personally who are saying, oh, it'll
alter your DNA or you're going to get microchips
by the vaccine. I know that a lot of people
believe that because I've seen the data, seen
the surveys, but I don't know any of those folks
personally. What I'm seeing mostly in the people
I know who are saying they're not planning to get
vaccinated, or at least not for now, is lack of
information. They're just ignorant to the facts.
So, like, as one example, a friend of mine
a couple of weeks ago said, I'm not going
to I'm not even going to think about getting a
vaccine until they do the Phase three trials.
And I explained to him for the approved vaccines,
phase three trials have been done. I mean,
the phase three trials have been done for months.
And we got that data in November, December, and
it was reviewed by the FDA and then an emergency
use authorization was put forward. And he said,
really? No, I didn't know. And I said, yeah, I
mean that you need the phase three data. There
was a discussion last summer about do we not do we
do an emergency use order before finishing phase
three? If the data looks good, it wasn't done.
Phase three has been done. And once I explained
that to him, he said, oh, well, I guess I'll look
into it now. What was really kind of scary is he
works in the health care field. And we've we've
read about a number of a significant portion of
nurses and others working in the health care field
who are saying, I'm not going to get the vaccine.
So that's some some folks that I'm hearing
from who say they're not going to get it. It's
something like that. They don't think it's been
approved. They don't think phase three is done
or whatever the case may be. But phase three is
done and there is an emergency use authorization.
The other people that I personally know who
are, you know, refusing is a weird term now
because most of them aren't yet eligible.
But who are telling me they don't? A plan to
get a vaccine is that they're sort of saying it
as from a libertarian perspective, like they're
against forced vaccination. And I kind of point
out to them, if you're opting not to get it,
clearly you're not forced. And then this
gets into this weird discussion about,
well, if in order to fly, you are required to
have it, you are being forced to get it. And I
try to explain there's a difference between
mandatory and required for certain activities.
And I end up kind of coming back to the same
place from this libertarian perspective, which is
as a libertarian, do you respect the right
of just hypothetically Delta Airlines to say
we require people who want to fly with us to
present proof of vaccination after a certain
date and they end up usually in a pretzel of
some kind where they are uber libertarians who
think businesses shouldn't be regulated, they
should be allowed to do whatever they want.
And yet somehow they want to be able to decide
what Delta's policy should be. And if they want
to fly without a vaccine, they should be allowed
to. You've got you've got to be a little more
consistent here. And there is not going to be
a mandatory vaccination from the government.
There's no legal basis to do that. But that
being said, there are all sorts of different
institutions that might say if you want to
choose to avail yourself of our product or
service or to do business with us, one of our
requirements is that you be vaccinated. And
this is not legally problematic. This is not
constitutionally an issue, et cetera. Now,
in terms of the number of people remaining in the
U.S. who don't plan to get the vaccine, I don't
know whether to say we're in a good place or we're
not in a good place. There was a point months and
months ago where more than half the country
said they did not plan to get a coronavirus
vaccine. That number is down to about a third
of the country and it continues to go down.
It's good that the percentage of people who don't
plan to get it has basically dropped by half.
The concerning part is that I don't know that
with two thirds of adult getting the vaccine,
two thirds of adults getting it and one third
not that we're going to reach herd immunity.
And that's really the concern at this point.
Dr. Fauci and others have said in particular,
since we're not going to be vaccinating
kids in the immediate, we need close to
all adults to get the vaccine, particularly with
these more transmissible variants, to really have
herd immunity and protection.
So that there's good news here,
which is vaccine hesitancy is declining. The bad
news is there's still a lot of people, including
otherwise educated individuals, who think
everything from the vaccine will alter your DNA
to it'll allow the government to track you.
Oh, which reminds me, there is one acquaintance,
this is not a friend, but it's an acquaintance
who posted to Facebook not long ago,
I have some reasonable concerns about the
vaccine. I'm not saying I'm not going to get it,
but I do believe this, that and that it could be
used to track my location. And a lot of our shared
friends started trying to talk her off the ledge.
I just had to unfriend. It's just I can't do it,
guys. I can't do it. And I know many of you
have come up against the same situation.